[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of fandango indie
movie guide and today I have some
fantastic movies for you three of which
called the and then something beginning
with B they're all worth your while so
let's get stuck into it
my first the B movie is the big dick
written by Kemal Nanjiani from Silicon
Valley along with his wife Emily V
Gordon and this is based on the story of
how these two met
Emily's character in the film is played
by Zoe Kazan and it starts out as a very
sweet very funny romantic comedy looking
at an interracial relationship listen
thank you very much I'm just going to
like Holly over go home and I hope I
just travel will be ready soon as he put
on his pants then things take a turn
when Zoe's carried to get sick after
they have broken up and Camille's
character has to figure out whether he
should stick around with her parents
while she gets better or not you really
don't have to stay come on you have
already done I just gonna stare for a
second it's this seat that's where the
drama kicks in and this movie really
will hit you in so many different places
first your funny bone because Kemal I
love his sense of humor and that shines
through in this film
secondly the feels because it is a very
sweet romantic movie and thirdly in your
tear ducts because this film deals with
a very serious illness and you see the
effect it has on her family
so 911 I've always wanted to have a
conversation with people you've never
talked to people about 911 it's an
incredible blend of romance comedy and
drama and it really shows how masterful
a director Michael Showalter is that he
was able to blend them all seamlessly I
highly highly recommend you check out
the big sick it is one of my favorite
films of the year thus far and I'm sure
it will be one of my favorite films come
the end of 2017
it's our limited theaters this weekend
and then we'll be going wide from July
14 my next the B movie is the bad batch
directed by anna lilly annew poor who
was behind a girl walks home alone at
night which was an Iranian vampire
Western this is another genre movie
turned on its head it's a cannibal
dystopian thriller Suki Waterhouse plays
a young girl who is put out to the
desert to fend for herself against some
violent cannibals also weave in some
cult dynamics some LSD type fever dreams
and a brilliant cameo by Jim Carrey and
a great role for Keanu Reeves mix it all
together
adding Jason Momoa and you have the bad
batch all the things you've done
and put you right here with me this here
is the bad batch it's a completely
original very unique film I'm sure it
will polarize audiences I just thought
it was a breath of fresh air in a super
cool movie the bad batch has been
described as Mad Max meets The Texas
Chainsaw Massacre
I think that's a pretty apt description
you can see the bad batch out in limited
theaters this weekend here's the thing
being good bad mostly depends on how
you're standing next to my third the
b-movie is the beguiled directed by
Sofia Coppola use my hands a lot don't I
this is the film which won Sophia the
Best Director award at the Cannes Film
Festival and it's very easy to see why
it's an atmospheric gothic twisted
thriller you see dad no get him inside
this time you have Nicole Kidman playing
the head of a southern girls boarding
school during the Civil War whose lives
are disrupted when a Yankee soldier
played by Colin Farrell comes to their
place bleeding and needing help it seems
the enemy it's not what we believe I
hope you like apple pie
is that my recipe it is alongside Colin
Farrell this movie features a badass
cast of fantastic ladies it's brimming
with gender politics and sex and
violence and take some unexpected twists
and turns
bring me the anatomy book can I get you
anything give me the key you know I can
call the beguiled is like the cherry on
top of the cream pie which is kind of
her filmography and everything that
she's done this but just go with me on
that one and definitely go and see the
beguiled one of my favorite films of
this year as well it comes out this
weekend
moving away now from movies starting
with the and be to a documentary that
you can see at home this weekend on
Netflix called
nobody speak trials of the free press
this takes a look at several events that
have been happening here in America
including Trump as president and the
Hulk Hogan sex tape trial and looks at
the wider implications of what happens
when powerful figures take on an attack
the Free Press billionaire Peter teal a
co-founder of PayPal is secretly paying
the expenses of Hulk Hogan's legal fight
the story about his sexual orientation
was published nine years before this
lawsuit this is personal he's doing this
because he wants to bring golfer down
billionaires are proclaiming we are more
powerful than the truth this is a moment
of real definition for the press this
film will make you think and it's a very
important issue that we should all be
discussing right now the future of
journalism the future of media you can
see nobody speak trials of the Free
Press it's the perfect film to watch at
home this weekend and it's on Netflix
from June 23 here's a message to the
White House you keep lying
we're gonna keep reporting the President
believes the brass is a threat to the
concert if facts are not facts it's an
office
honey can't silence the
so to recap there's three movies that
are worth your time this weekend or
beginning with the and B you have the
rom-com drama the big sick the cannibal
dystopian thriller the bad batch the
gothic Civil War sexy drama the beguiled
and over on Netflix you've got the
documentary nobody speak trials of the
free press I highly recommend all of
these films this weekend so note them
down if they're not in your area or your
country hopefully you'll get to see them
their hashtag Alicia approved and as
always let me know in the comments below
what you've been watching what tickles
your fancy this week or you can find me
on Twitter at Alicia Malone and I'll see
you next week bye
[Music]